bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon sicilienne major le coup six f4
avec pour présenter cette émission
stéphane laborde qui nous fait l'honneur
de porter la barbe en ce moment bonjour
stéphane raymond jouets loi je vais
pousser un peu d'abord c'est pour
acquérir plus de sagesse et jouer les
positions avec plus de deux temps
tranquillement quoi tout en sérénité
donc la sicile ndash dorff
on en a déjà parlé il ya eu beaucoup
d'émissions qui ont été consacrés c'est
une arme violente pour le gain et en
jouant cette option avec six f4 et bien
le joueur qui allait blanc tente de vous
compterez est d'amener la position sur
un terrain équilibré en fait ils jouent
pour la nul hein vous pour la nulle
intention il faut aussi jouer pour le
gain si on fait pas attention il va
falloir réagir justement de façon
appropriée exactement alors des très
fort joueur on employer cette arme avec
six f4 c'est le choix par exemple de
peter l'écho qu'ils aient joué ça
pendant très longtemps également andré
sokolov parmi les efforts joueur josep
qu'est la guerre tout un tas de très
forts grands maîtres ont choisi cette
arme avec six f4 alors tout de suite
nous allons passer en pastilles pour
vous montrer la position
c'est parti la fameuses pastilles voit
la pastille look sicilienne donc ces
scènes qu on rappelle stéphane que le
thème de l'émission c'est qu'on a les
noirs qu'on veut jouer la cécilienne
l'âge d'or ouais et donc qu'on veut voir
une solution adaptée pour jouer contre
ce coup ci c'est 4 donc on détaille pas
les options des noirs et seulement celle
des blancs tout à fait khalef trois des
six normales des 4 juin prenait 4 ans
reprend du cavalier on attaque le pion
central développement nuque avec un c3
tout ça et on l'a déjà vu plusieurs fois
à 6 on rentre d'un fameuse un âge d'or
la neige dorff et là c'est là que nous
avons déjà traité beaucoup d'options
notamment la sortie du four 3 qu'est la
plus dangereuse et qui est dangereuse
la sortie du fond ces quatre là sorti du
fond de nous avons traité ces trois
coups il reste donc le coup j'ai ça on
verra plus tard
et également le coup f4 c'est celui
qu'on regarde aujourd'hui six f4
stéphane c'est un coût qui on peut le
dire néglige la sortie des pièces donc a
priori pas forcément alors dans un
premier temps sa bouche un peu la sortie
du phocéen
ce fou c'est maintenant a du mal à
sortir puisque s'ils viennent sur la
case de trois maintenant son cavalier 4
on n'a pas la possibilité de jouer le
coup manger 5
donc il débouchait par le pion f4 par
contre ça instaure le contrôle de la
case e 5
tout à fait f4 ça installe tout de suite
le duo de pions donc ça peut préparer
des f-5 ça peut préparer des eaux 5 ça
prépare beaucoup de choses la
contrepartie directe de scouts de pions
c'est on le verra dans beaucoup beaucoup
de variantes cette diagonale là qui
commence à s'agrandir et qui est donc
affaibli puisqu'ils appliquions f2 ouais
on rappelle tard hachadi l'option bref
on avance toujours trop tôt donc il ya
énormément thème basé sur scène
notamment quand on aura rouquet avec les
blancs et bien le ku'damm b6 est aurora
soir une clouage du câble et des quatre
soit avoir un échec voire un échec et
éventuellement la taille du pion b2
voilà donc les inconvénients a priori de
ce coup ci ce f4 la réaction des noirs
il faut pas jouer avec le 6 parce que
jouer avec eux si c'est un peu petit
bras dans cette position table ça rame
dans le pire dans le plein des blancs
pour jouer cinq exactement
et en plus ce n'est pas adapté puisque
on ne chasse pas lequel des cartons
qu'on n'essaie pas d'exploiter la
diagonale donc premier 1er premier
indice pour vous rappeler qu'il faut
jouer et bien on commence par chasser le
cavalier des cadres pour pouvoir
profiter de cette grande diagonale noir
est ouverte vers le petit roekeghem donc
on répond tout de suite violemment vers
le centre vers le centre en jouant le
coup au 7e 5 premiers
première chose surtout si on prend un
sens qu'on n'a pas peur on reprend du
pied et quelqu'un m'a dit bouge
en échange les dames ouais c'est
tranquille c'est tout à fait tranquille
d'autant plus que les blancs sont
rassemblement objet de prendre du roi
pour ne pas perdre le pion de 4 donc ça
pas de problème il faut que les blancs
bougent leur cave a dit ils vont donc
sur la kf3 case extrêmement logique
puisque maintenant de dire qu'ils
attaquent ce pion wim nation prononcé
incrimination 35 autre chose et bien si
on prend en f4 devient tout de suite il
y à fond pour un f4 avec un très bon
développement des pièces rengaine temps
un tempo bien le temps et que ça me
dirait notre ami d'ami relève ainsi qu
avec avec tes goûts on joue donc à la
libé 17 ont des fractures aux cinq tout
simplement
en attendant de voir comment les blancs
vont se développer alors les blancs dans
cette position eh bien il pourrait
sortir leur fou pour le tir hommes mais
ils ont très peur du coup b5
oui puisque sur fous ces 4 par exemple
b5 suivi éventuellement de bay 4-1 le
piano 4 tout à fait alors ça c'est
thématiques mais b5 suivi également de
fougue et cette mouais si on est pas si
on veut pas jouer bep cap qui est comme
un coup complexe dont on n'a pas sorti
trop pièce n'a pas envie de jouer b5
bécade pour prendre le client 4 donc b5
je suis troublé cette tout simplement va
contrôler la casse des cinq classes très
importante attaque et le quai henri iv
donc il a pas envie qu'on joue b5 c'est
normal donc les banques jouent
généralement à cap dans cette position
le champ des cinq ans je donc fou aux
sept développement et ici il y a deux
variantes possibles pour les blancs la
moins dangereuse étant la première qu'on
va vous montrer c'est le coup choisi par
peter l'écho dans cette partie c'est fou
ces 4 on verra tout à l'heure que la
plus dangereuse c'est de mettre le foin
en d3 pour bien protéger
alors il ya peut-être une autre option
qui est serait de jouer à 5 empêché en
2005 et contrainte d'un v6 dans toutes
les variantes
c'est vrai mais c'était fanny faut pas
oublier qu à cinq est une perte de temps
et ça serait un pion faible ça serait
éventuellement un pion fable est donc
sûre à 5 ans je vois tout simplement
petit robe dans un premier temps ensuite
on irait prendre en f4 et jouer cavalier
5 très vite et j'en sors le fou s'est
vite moi là nous avons un développement
de pièces tout à fait normal et ce pion
à 5 finalement sera en prise elle sera
faible il faudra que la tour est là pour
le protéger tout à fait donc à 5 n'est
pas vraiment un fou qui doit vous faire
peur ou ses quatre tentatives de picard
l'écossé quand même du sérieux le fou
vient naturellement
cette grande diagonale attaqué le plus
bref c'est ce qui semble logique puisque
les noirs ayant joué e5 qui n'ont pas
aussi ce oui cette diagonale et semi
ouverte on va dire kazim pour le fou
exactement en plus avec petit rock on
aura une tour en f1 on voit que cette
colonne demande qu'à s'ouvrir
ouais on a aussi des cavaliers g5 qui
traîne bref on peut mettre la pression
sur ce point faisait donc vous c4 est un
coût tout à fait logique
garry kasparov réagi de façon très
dynamique il joue damas cinq dames à
cinq premières menaces cavaliers
pression locale oui puisque le cas les
c3 est cloué il est cloué qu'est ce
qu'on a envie de faire ici stéphane ont
envie de rock et même petit rock ça
enlève le clouage petit rocco relève le
clouage mais inconvénient majeur de
petits os stéphane c'est que ce
atteindrait une pièce il ya un piège
il ya un piège après petit rock le roi
se retrouvent en général et donc on joue
d'un à cinq ans et cinq échecs on rend
cette fameuse rendiez le voir il faut
parer les chèques et d'un prince et
carré d'un procès quatre hamas le fou
donc ici on ne peut pas jouer petit rock
c'est un premier thème avec cette
diagonale dont des fractures 4 comme on
peut dames 200 m dames de pau alors 5
août dame contrecoup dame finalement un
coude d'amour entre époux de dame imelda
may 5 peut-être plus actif que la dame
en deux une case clé pour les noirs
c'est la case aux cinq dans cette
pétition va tout de suite voir pourquoi
donc la casse ford joue petit rock petit
rock et maintenant ils jouent que pour
un f4 quand même quand même donc les
blancs naturellement je vous fous pour
un f4 et maintenant comme la dame étant
à cinq on peut jouer le cavalier aux
cinq voix là puisque sinon quand la
salle là mais terme des huit c'était pas
possible puisqu'il ya deux pièces
blanches qui contrôle le 5
donc ici maintenant on voit ya de
défense l'option des 6es la nasa qui
défend nos quelque 5
donc pas de problème quel est l'intérêt
de choix qu'avait lieu 5 et bien tout
simplement stéphane deçà des plis les
pièces tandis avoir sorti ça libère le
fou s'est vite et puis le cabillaud cinq
attaques le pouce et 4 déjà oui donc sa
menace éventuelle union fou donc on va
revoir les quelques coups précédents et
eu tout simplement petit rock des noirs
après damas cinq petit rock
ici on est devant l'obligation je dirais
prendre f4 il faut le faire pour pouvoir
sortir nos pièces donc c'est exactement
ce qui se passe on joue en pro f 4 fours
en f4 cavagnoud 5 pour sortir les pièces
c'est vraiment une manoeuvre de
développement
après calvillo 5,6 les blancs rouges le
fou une façon normale par exemple je
m'en fous des 3 et bien beaucoup
d'options on peut jouer rouge et quatre
rouges gaza c'est une première option
qui tout le cavalier faut aussi ce
peut-être fou aussi ce qui est
intéressant également mais a priori on
jouera quand même fou g4 donc ici peter
l'écho tente le coup cavani des 5 alors
c'est intéressant ce coup parce que ça
va fort sa force la réponse des noirs cd
toujours des coups assez intéressant
quand ça limite les opportunités
adverses puisque là il ya une double
menace ses cavaliers prendre un set avec
l'échec gagne un fou et la deuxième
menace c'est de prendre le 5 avec le
cavalier gagnant option tout à fait donc
surtout qu'ils avaient les provinces est
une menace totalement inadmissible faut
donc éliminer ce qui valide et sain qui
est très précaire et prend des cinq
fours en d5 important de prendre du fou
puisque le foot attaqué par le cavalier
et en plus si on avait pris du coup on
aurait bouché la démo neil du fou
exactement
il faut toujours prendre le fouet en
plus effectivement c'est cette colonne
des qui est quand même qui tape sur le
plan des six on n'a pas envie de la
bouche est fou aux six sorties de pièces
tout à fait classique normal tranquille
quelle est l'idée de se coucher au cices
et bien c'est de jouer stéphane comprend
des 5 1 là on arrive dans une structure
de sicilienne tout à fait classique une
structure de cécilienne chef dingue
comme on l'a déjà vu et dès qu'on arrive
justement sortir toutes nos pièces et
bien il n'y a pas de problème d'autant
plus qu'il ya toujours dans le vent ce
dôme b6 échec la suite d'un premier
dodin promet de pas forcément bon tout
le temps puisque derrière les pions des
cette emprise
ouais mais en tout cas ça traîne fois
c'est à dire qu'on pourrait jouer une
tour sur la dame
la dame bougé après tout reprend 17
exactement fou aux six dans cette
position le seul problème que pourrait
avoir les noirs cécile et blanc prenez
et entre 6 et ans le 5 et que les noirs
soient obligés de reprendre avec les
pions à chaque fois ça donnerait des
pions doublé donc faibles donc ici il ya
deux possibilités soit on joue cavalier
prendre cinq options qui n'est pas
choisie par khiter l'écho merkel prend
1,5 soit tout simplement à petit au
programme 5 je pense peut-être comprend
un sac peut-être également fou prend des
seringues des 5es des pions prono 5
effectivement comprendre 5 / fou prend
2,6 maintenant on ne prend pas évident
ici bien prendre un f4 comprend f4
sémaphore continué d'attaquer le fou 6
en attaque le fou maintenant le four a
trouvé une très belle diagonale ans m6
puis éventuellement se placer sur la
case aux 5
ici pas de problème donc ça c'est
important à voir puisque après flo 6
maintenant fou prend aussi c'est le
choix de picardie qu on ne joue pas pu
reprendre aussi stéphane pour éviter ces
fabuleux en double et on joue les
chèques intermédiaire cavaliers pros 9,3
d'abord à cheikh est après d'âpres ans
puis on prend 1,6 donc maintenant
effectivement les noirs une structure de
pions légèrement moins bonne que les
blancs moi c'est celle ci font ça se
défend il ya trois îlots et trois îlots
azillois dire trois îlots de pions des
deux côtés seulement quand même les
pions au cices des six sont assez
faibles mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est
l'activité des noirs avec une tour forte
un fou qui menacent de venir en aide 6
lionel forte donc ici de l'activité
dernière chose à voir dans cette partie
c'est la suite forcé dame b trois
attaques de pions attaque bessette et
aux six des sept m6 hélas la défense
dams et cinq échecs rush 1 dames s'est
vite et même ses villas d'un protège des
deux pions tout à fait et là on voit que
les coûts les noirs ont simplement je
vous donne 17 ou des coups comme ça des
coups solides toc ou encore tours a des
seins et b5
le coût final de garry kasparov après ça
il a une activité largement suffisante
pour compenser donc cette partie
peter l'écho garry kasparov s'est
achevée par une nulle rapide voilà ça
c'était donc la première partie on va
passer à la suivante qui est une partie
gala guerre contre vos shsh divx grand
maître totalement polonais totalement de
polonais et gala guerre lui sait c'est
un axe anglais suisses oui c'est ça mais
on a gagné
oui les anglais mais il est aussi suisse
ouais double donc il peut gagner les
deux championnats
vous êtes donc tout ça c'est des coupons
vous êtes déjà commenté on les passe
donc rapidement
4-5 qualif 3d c'est toujours un crac
pour empêcher distingue fawcett
c'est fou des trois fautes et 3 non
classés peuvent tous ces cas là on
change exactement on change tout de
suite on défend bien le pion du capital
et kobe choisi fous ces quatre là c'est
fou d'être un petit rock normale petit
rock petit rock & cie très important on
prend en f4 alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
et bien sûr prévu 4 c'est normal et là
on a plus la dame 1 à 5 pour pour jouer
car il ya eu cinq exactement mais par
contre en revanche
eh bien il ya une grosse différence
majeure c'est qu'après fou pour un f4
on verra que ce n'est pas le principal
locaux principal 0 h 1 il y as dame b 6
échecs
oui mais oui toujours c'était pas de
cette fameuse grande diagonale qui est
vraiment thématique 20 tables et 6 et on
voit que le pion b2 est en prison les
samoa les blancs prévus c'est un [ __ ]
ou choisissez effectivement sacrifice
qui peut s'avérer dangereux mais qui ne
l'est pas réellement rouach un dame
prend b2 alors intéressant parce que ce
coût d'un produit en plus à table comme
les c3 donc tempo exactement comme
dirait des biens comme dirait dernière
le massif avec tempo qui a validé ce 1 1
je dis ça parce qu'il a dit ça souvent
dans les commentaires
cavalier prend cahier des cinq ouais
normal puis on prend des saints qui là
nous arrivons sur la pression critique
de cette piste de pions d'où l'on voit
ici que le fou détroit est un bon coup
puisque maintenant ce fou à une très
belle diagonale qui prennent sur l'euro
adverse a noté stéphane que le fou prend
1,7 coûts qui seraient thématique n'est
pas possible dans cette poule
malheureusement ça marche pas puisque le
fawcett contrôler la tête g5 oui en plus
c'est au noir de jouer ça c'est vrai que
c'est parce que en fait on fait souvent
faut expliquer pourquoi on fait souvent
fourrage cet effet qu owen roi prend et
ensuite cavalier j 5 échecs suivi de en
général la dame h5 tmg quatre verges et
quatre en fonction de l'endroit où elle
est le
roy avec une grosse attaque mais là
c'est pas possible puisque sur kaia g5
échec qu'on ferait tout simplement
pourquoi
en cavale il y aurait pu d'attac
exactement dans cette position les noirs
ont plusieurs options
il y as dame b sides mb2 en b 6 mais ça
ça va contre les principes parce qu'en
principe stéphane quand on a une dame
avancé dans le coin nuit et qu'on a pris
du matériel avec il faut la laisser là
pour faire diversion faut la laisser là
pour faire diversion exactement puisque
les blancs ont tendance à perdre du
temps pour la chasse est différée pas si
mal placées elles contrôlent une belle
diagonale quand même l'un exactement le
des bonal b2g 7 dans un endroit qui
défendent qui défend le roi et puis bon
elle fait un peu pression sur le camp
sur le camp blanc un principe une fois
de plus puisque c'est quand même le
thème de la leçon est bien quand vous
avez un point de plus et changer les
pièces évidemment moins il ya de pièces
- iliad attaque donc moyens de
compensation pour l'option sacrifier
donc cavalier c5 en plus on n'élimine
pas n'importe quelle pièce puisqu'on
elin se fout des trois qui étaient quand
même un fou méchant oui alors d'où
l'intérêt sukuk halal c'est 5 1 ça
permet d'envisager un échange de pièces
et deux ça libère le fou s'est vite et
ça permet d'envisager un autre échange
de pièces puisqu'on peut envisager sous
g4 pour échanger le cas mais les sept
rencontres le cavaliere 3 tout
simplement une fois qu'on ait changé
toutes les pièces et bien on va tout
simplement gagner la partie avec un
point de plus ça se voit régulièrement
donc ici cette menace ou g4 est très
pénible longue à la guerre pour l'éviter
genou damien dame un attaquant le fouet
cette donc encore une fois avec tempo
avec tempo attaque fawcett vous remettre
la dame sur laquelle j'ai 3 d'où elle
attaquera le pion des 6 1 avec un fou et
éventuellement créer des menaces sur le
roi crée des menaces eurent droit donc
ici cavale et prend des trois on ne
craint pas d'un procès de stéphane
puisque et encore le fauteuil wild 4 qui
narre une pièce tu en prends des trois
normales alors là les pions blancs ils
ont l'air ils ont l'air vraiment un
piteux état
tout à fait mais les noirs ou un
problème qu'il faut résoudre c'est le
faut s'attaquer le pion des six aux six
mois elle sert fou et 6 le retrait à
[ __ ] en d6 est justement stéphane pas
tout à fait puisqu'il ya foxes pour m6
quand même qui menace d'un pro tour un
échange
enfin gagné en qualité ouais qualité on
le rappelle c'est un faux pour une tour
dames 4 défense maintenant ça devient
très dangereux de jouer dame prend
taurin puisqu'après tout reprend en
souffrent c'est ainsi on prend là la
tour reprend et le fond reprend
le fou n'est plus en défense il peut y
avoir des g5 qui arrive voire même des
fous prendrait six mois il y aurait
quand même nombreuses attaques sur le
roi il ya du jeu c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on a dans cette position il faut
sortir les pièces on peut prendre deux
tours pour la dame mais ça dépend de la
position en l'état comme les piles et
noir sont quand même pas très bien
développé il reste encore le fou
s'éviter la torah 8 qui cherchent à
savoir où une immense place et il ya eu
les blancs peuvent monter une attaque
développement est très important donc
ici on se fout des sept en tout cas
c'est gauche qui est x qui joue faux 17
qui est un grand spécialiste la neige
d'or avec l'idée évidemment de mettre
les tours une tour sur la colonne peut
ainsi pas encore laquelle il reprend le
pion des six il leur donne c'est
possible de points blancs de le prendre
et d'ailleurs ils vont le prendre mais
pas tout de suite a tout de suite tombé
un abord tourbe et un internat soir
attaque le pion à kaya avec tempo là ils
font tout reprendre et cette attaque le
fou 17
à noter comme à troyes la dame protéger
voilà la dame est venue protéger le pion
des six tours prend 17 maintenant tours
la partie a encore continué de toute
façon il faut choisir un angle pour
s'arrêter stéphane est bien ici je crois
que c'est clair que les noirs déjà n'ont
plus aucun problème les 1 la paire de
fou fluxys très fort ces gens à quatre
reprises il va être pris ce plan c'est
sûr par le foot 17 ou par la dame qui
est attaquée ou quand la dame qui peut
descendre ou la tour en 1 8es très fort
il y aura un pion à passer avec une tour
derrière c'est toujours intéressant tout
à fait donc ici de toute façon ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que l'activité des noirs
est forte
2 les blancs pas d' attaque et 3 la
structure d'options des blanches est
affaibli donc tout simplement il n'y a
pas eu vraiment de compensation pour le
sacrifice d'options donc on vous
remontre depuis le début ce qui s'est
passé après j'en prends un f4 fou pour
un f4 demba cissé cheikh rouach d'un
premier 200 bulls est le fils attaque
look et ses 3 il faut aller en des cinq
cavaliers préemption prend hélas il faut
échanger les pièces en jeu donc qu'elle
et ses 5 menace ou gk menace carrément
fou détroit avec déjà une position tout
à fait agréable à jouer il suffit de pas
se faire enfermer la dame c'est
important suffit d'aller changer les
pièces et de rendre le pion netease de
données dans des conditions qui seront
avantageuses voilà donc comment contrer
sa piste
une nouvelle partie c'est la partie
freyssinet rôle anges voilà j'ai deux
parties donc championnat de france je
crois à 96 amérique d'elle donc laurent
frayssinet le jeune aux dents longues
ouais à l'époque ne savait pas très bien
que je contrôle la nage torse donc il
jouer cette variante avec f4 ouais il
voulait la jouer solide au sein qui
n'ont que 5 kg vif trois cas les bd
celle de 17 à 4 normal fawcett vous
défendez 3 petit rock petit rock tu
apprends à 1.94 et l'a donc la voir la
partie qu'on vient de voir
il ya eu foule point f4 voilà ce qui
permet donc d'amener six échecs alors là
les blancs par le coût principal de
cette position se débarrasse de tous les
problèmes sur ses diagonales en jour le
courage ou h
voilà il fera plus d'échecs ya plus
d'échecs maintenant évidemment ils
veulent reprendre le club ouais ça c'est
clair donc il faut le défendre
camani ashton ouais ou jouer aux dames
b6 pour empêcher la dame bref c'est pas
tout à fait mais la dame des cistes la
retraire à 5 peut-être examen à les
organiser dans les gains de temps très
fort des miens temps sur la dame la dame
sait pas où aller oui parce que si elle
vient en bkt bien voire risquer de se
faire enfermer alors il n'aura qu'à 24
ça va pas du tout ouais donc ici il faut
jouer cavalier seul pour défendre ses
pions voilà ce que si les banques
reprennent ils vont être mieux donc ça
ressemble un peu un gambit du roi un
petit peu un petit peu en prend le pion
et on défend voyez on le défend avec le
cavalier tout à fait deux grands coups
dans cette variante qu'on va regarder
rapidement il ya le coup qu'eva lieu un
éclat et des caps qui ont tous les deux
des avantages et inconvénients
différents le coup cavalier est
intéressant puisqu'il permet de
récupérer le plus enlevant fouet 2 et
cavaliers detroit après pour les
reprendre le club k way et le coup qui a
aidé quatre c'est celui de la partie on
va le voir tout de suite au qe2 le
compte de frayssinhes le coup de facile
freyssinet g6 on défend le cafouillage
s'en fout d'eux donc l'amener à ce fou
prend 5 avec un désastre désastre
complet c'est à dire qu'on
déjà les blancs récupérerez pions après
d'âpres en achetant la structure de
pions noirs seraient totalement affaibli
le roi noir serait faible
c'est inadmissible donc il faut
absolument jouer le coup voilà cavale et
6 donc les deux cavaliers se protègent à
noter qu'avec une structure comme ça il
n'y a jamais de g4 pour attaquer le
cavaliere 5 puisqu'il a toujours pu
engranger trois la prise en passant la
fin on a toujours la prise en passant
pas délicate ici laurent frayssinet joue
la variante dans l'esprit c'est fou
proches cinq cavaliers pros h5 et
cavaliers des cinq qui va récupérer le
plomb f4 mais là tout simplement les
noirs ont un moyen extrêmement sûre
d'égaliser cette partie voire même de
prendre un petit avantage
on nous fout g5 on consolide le plus
bref là pour échanger des pièces
voilà on veut changer les pièces est
arrivé dans la position qui de toute
façon va arriver puisque les blancs
n'ont pas le choix ils doivent reprendre
7 9 4
donc ils prennent on prend vous prend
cavaliers prend tout reprend ce qu'on
appelle un échange généralisé et
maintenant pour bien jouer cette
position est bien il faut un sortir
cette tour et la mettre sur la colonne
eux
ouais 2 donc trouver une case pas trop
bête pour le fou pour faire ça ouais
pareil pour la dame est ensuite au bon
moment jouer des six des cinq
échantillons les pions et le fou sera
supérieur au québec
donc c'est ce qui a suivi dans la partie
est-ce qu'on va pas rapidement d'un v6
un tacle puis en b2 effectivement un
petit au passage un petit coup sur la
jambe et 2b 3 fou 17 on voit jeu
extrêmement simple donc dans le rôle de
l'asean case par comtal intéressante
parce que
le contrôle toutes les cases des
cavaliers qui sont déjà contrôlés par
des pions parlant on peut se poser la
question c'était fans toujours est-ce
que c'est fou qui domine le cavalier ou
le cabinet qui depuis neuf mois et
toujours un petit peu ambigu s'est
toujours défini fin délicat
en tout cas ici fu 17 c'est un coup tout
simplement vous sortir le fou pour m la
tour sur la colonne dam des trois tours
a eu huit tours à f1 non non vous
emmener les siens de faire pression sur
le pion essentiel qui est pas vraiment
faible qui est bien protégé qui est bien
protégé tours 7
donc là ça y est on va on veut doubler
sur la colonne eux est attaqué depuis en
tout cas tout simplement tout à fait et
les blancs dans ce pays ont donc tout
simplement plus plan à leur disposition
ils ne savent plus quoi faire
donc laurent frayssinet joué tour m6
dame c5 et d'un médecin qu'on améliore
encore la position de nos pièces ont
effectivement il est revenu dans cette
position il sait plus quoi faire et
maintenant des six des 5 qui arrive avec
égalisation complète des noirs voire
même un léger avantage puisque on voit
que les tours seront mieux placés que
les tours blanches
donc ce coup stéphane on va le revoir
puisque on s'intéresse même
principalement l'ouverture après pions
3f quatre roues h 15 10 h 5
le couple laurent frayssinet le choix
laurent frayssinet qu'avec des quatre
n'est pas très dangereux
ouais pour ça hein on défend le cavalier
hi5 avec l'option on joue chez six là
les blancs attaques locales liées à
chaque iphone ont leurs défauts un
cahier dé f6 pour reprendre ce pion f4
et bien y'a pas d'autres choix il faut
prendre cinq cavaliers prend et qui a
aidé cinq mois là pour attaquer deux
fois avec le cavalier le fou le pian
leucate et lattes en élimine notre
mauvais fou le fou au set en jouant fou
g5 échange généralisé en f4 et là c'est
gagné
vous n'avez plus qu'à sortir votre tour
dans les six ou 17 tours 8 donc c'est
pas très très dangereux maintenant on
arrive à la pression la plus dangereuse
c'est la dernière le choix de christian
bauer contre boris défendre donc on va
voir tout de suite les premiers coups
qui sont une fois de plus les mêmes ne
joue pas contre n'importe qui y est plus
bauer la joue contre boris gelfand donc
pas forcément une partie facile mais
avec ce choix f4 il espère avoir une
position solide petit rock tu reprends
avec 4 3 h un voyage 5 est maintenant
cavalier e 1 pas pareil que tu avais des
quatre un peu différent
alors ici
petite astuce qui est très bien c'est le
coût qui avait lieu le 5 alors lequel
des acheteurs qui avaient l'air
emprisonné stefan wey donc il faut
regarder ce qui se passe quand même si
on comprend bien si il ya le petit piège
fou j'ai quatre fous g4 et jean ping the
queen i way et the queen a plus de cases
la dame est enfermée elle ne peut pas
prendre le fou cause du cavalier et
toutes les autres cas sont contrôlées
par des pièces voilà le fou contrôler la
se fout la contrôler
là et là se fout là contrôle ici et les
pions contrôle le reste
la dame n'a plus de gaz donc ici on peut
jouer le coup cavaliers ou cinq cas un
bon coup puisque puisque le cavaly bien
placés ici tout simplement et en plus ça
défend indirectement que l'alliage sa
fourrure de renard y allèrent logique
maintenant que le feu est parti en deux
cas on n'a plus aucune raison les biens
sont désorganisés on revient - f6 alors
on a perdu de temps mais on a mille
cavaliers en scène qu'est ce qu'on avait
dit être un plan intéressant dans cette
nasse est parti puisque maintenant après
fou prend f4 on joue au cices et là on a
notre position rêvée de la chef d'un
gang stéphane lui avec toutes les pièces
bien placé on vous montre la suite de la
partie rapidement mais déjà à partir
d'ici si vous avez un bon feeling dans
la sicilienne cette position ne doit pas
vous faire peur on regarde la suite
assez rapidement avant de conclure
qu'avec des trois cavaliers g6 fou j'ai
trois des cinq coups thématique la
poussée libératrice qui était inévitable
fouet f3 l'on peut prendre quatre avec
une nulle immédiate beauce galfond de
choisi de jouer des quatre pour le gain
possible de gagner il y avait beaucoup
d'embranchements possible et finalement
évidemment la partie a été nulle présent
lower ayant serré la vis donc c'est
solide pour les blancs mais avec les
noirs si on joue assez précis en risque
pas de perdre mais on peut avoir même un
peu d'initiative tout à fait donc là en
fait vous n'avez pas grand chose à
craindre donc rappelez vous bien de
toutes les routes qu'on a dit le premier
coup c'est fou ces cartes le choix de
pierre les bons coups dangereux
là il faut jouer damas 5 justement pour
clouer le quai vallet c3 et ensuite
avoir la case aux 5 pour le cavalier sur
food et 3 quel coût principal il faut
penser à prendre 24 au bon moment quand
les blancs ne peuvent pas reprendre
sinon ils doivent donner le pion v2000
ça c'est la variante la deuxième partie
que nous avons vu et après 3h 1 et bien
il ya deux variantes à connaître et des
quatre cavaliers
sur quoi vous avez les deux parties qui
sont plus ou moins les parties de
référence et freyssinet relance et bauer
contre galles funds ou les noirs vont
jamais de problème donc voilà c'est fini
pour cette leçon avec f 4 c'est fini
pour cette leçon avec six f4 donc on
vous remercie d'avoir suivi l'émission
merci stéphane d'être une fois de plus
mais c'est normal et sain que vous en
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
diagonale la leçon toujours sur la
défense nador merci de nous avoir suivis